well what I'd like to know is would a
magnet car swallow a black hole or would
a black hole gobble up a magnetar
although magnetars are incredibly
powerful they would lose the battle with
a black hole
depending on the trajectory of the
magnetar as well as the size and mass of
both the magnetar and the black hole
the magnetic monster would be eaten up
either whole or slowly piece by piece
as the magnetar was being torn apart by
the black hole it would be sending
gravitational waves throughout the
Universe disturbing the curvature of
space-time
once the black hole consumed the
magnetar its mass would increase and
expand its Event Horizon and thanks to
this expansion more and more stars would
be flung into its dark density